nous sommes au Cégep régional de
Lanaudière à Joliette ces étudiantes de
première année en soins infirmiers
assisteront à une formation toute
particulière ma famille vient d'origine
de agrossos
des Premières nations à de futurs
infirmières dans ce cégep qui se situe à
quelque part de l'hôpital où est morte
Joyce et chacuan je le fais pour mes
enfants mes petits-enfants j'aimerais
bien que le monde change un peu pour
qu'il soit plus accueillant aux nations
autochtones cette conférence est une
initiative du Cégep j'aurais jamais pu
avoir le même impact qu'une personne
autochtone qui vient parler de sa
réalité des émotions ressentir quelque
chose ça ils vont s'en rappeler Diane
parle de culture mais aussi de la Loi
sur les Indiens des pensionnats et des
préjugés le racisme systémique existe
ici au Québec il devrait y avoir des
cours qui sont intégrés à l'intérieur de
toute formation surtout aux soins
infirmiers actuellement aucune formation
spécifique aux Premières nations n’est
obligatoire c'est très inégal selon les
programmes de formation que ce soit dans
les collèges ou dans les universités
selon un sondage de Loïc auprès des
établissements collégiaux donnant la
technique en soins infirmiers près d'un
cégep sur deux n'ont aucun cours
spécifique aux Premières nations et ceux
qui en ont offrent moins de 5 heures
pour intégrer à l'intérieur de leur
formation des notions de sécurisation
culturelles il faudrait que ça soit dans
un devis matériel qui obligerait tous
les cégep à mettre dans leur plan cadre
des éléments relatifs à la sécurisation
culturelle toute cette espèce
d'insécurité là envers les institutions
canadiennes québécoises on les a
colonisés on a fait un génocide après il
faut recréer il a une confiance le
ministère de l'enseignement supérieur
affirme avoir entamer la révision de la
formation collégiale en soins infirmiers
et assure qu'il y intégrera une
formation sur les Premières nations en
attendant Diane continue à livrer le
même message ce que je vous demande
c'est d'utiliser ce que vous avez vécu
aujourd'hui et de partager juste une
partie de ça avec ceux qui vous
entourent pour tracer le chemin vers la
réconciliation entre nous peuples ici
Marie-José paquet Comores au Canada
Joliette